une conférence particulièrement attendue
à l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique au cœur des discussions la
centrale nucléaire de zapporizia
nous devons faire tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir pour empêcher un accident
nucléaire qui ajouterait une tragédie à
la souffrance
la centrale nucléaire nous aporidja la
plus importante dukraine et la plus
vaste d'Europe un territoire comme
Moscou entend bien annexé avec Louhans
d'honnête et Kerson situé au sud-est de
l'Ukraine zapporijah et le cœur
nucléaire du pays
Louhans qui est honnête que constitue le
Dombas le bassin minier et metaurique de
l'Ukraine la région a majorité
russophone est l'une des plus riches du
pays enfin la région de Kerson est une
région agricole importante elle fait de
l'Ukraine le grenier bleu de l'Europe
face aux ambitions de Moscou l'Union
européenne n'a pas tardé à réagir avec
un huitième train de sanction parmi ces
mesures le plafonnement du prix du
pétrole russe l'interdiction d'exporter
vers l'Europe des diamants russes et
d'importer vers la Russie des composants
électroniques européens
enfin les personnalités européennes ne
pourront plus siéger dans des
entreprises russes l'objectif pour les
27 frapper et isoler totalement
l'économie russe
nous proposons donc de nouvelles
interdictions d'importation radicales
sur les produits russes cela les
éloignera du marché européen et privera
la Russie de 7 milliards d'euros de
revenus supplémentaires
ces nouvelles sanctions vont affaiblir
une économie déjà fragilisée d'après un
rapport secret russe dévoilé par les
médias l'économie de la Russie se
contracterait dans le meilleur des cas
de 3,8% l'année prochaine jusqu'à 11%
dans le pire des scénarios